welcome back I'm glad you could join me
for another go at trying to understand
some of the math behind quantum
mechanics last week I did sort of a
introduction to linear algebra and the
way that we saw how you can write out
quantum states and today we're going to
expand on that a little bit by linking
it to finding the probability of a
quantum state now I just want to say
thanks to everyone who left comments on
my last video like this I found them
really constructive some of you pointed
out like mistakes in my pronunciation
but also ways that I could have
explained things better and I guess
ideas that you had that I didn't include
as well
shoutout to comment of the day from
someone called Fred who I guess left a
lot of really constructive things in a
comment and one of the things he said
was when you were talking about spin it
was in a way that made it sound like it
had solely to do with magnetic moment in
fact spin is a carrier of angular
momentum
one of the universally conserved
physical quantities of nature it is
however a mysterious form of angular
momentum not being caused by any actual
physical rotation this is why it is
often termed intrinsic spin and seems to
be one of those essentially quantum
mechanical effects that can't be
understood in classical terms so thanks
for that comment Fred because I think I
yeah I didn't give like the best
explanation of quantum spin and I think
maybe that builds a little bit more on
what I said last time here's a little
problem to get you warmed up it's what
we're going to work towards
understanding throughout the course of
this episode so don't worry if you don't
already understand the math behind it
now but it's the math of the famous
thought experiment regarding
Schrodinger's cat in this thought
experiment we have a cat stuck in a
closed box with a poisoned vial and a
stern girl
analyzer which can measure the state of
a quantum particle it can measure the
particle to be either spin up or spin
down and this equation here represents
the input state of that quantum particle
the particle is in a superposition of
being spin up or spin down and if the
analyzer measures the particle to be
spin up then the poison will be released
and the cat will die so the cat is also
in a superposition of being alive and
dead the question is what is the
probability of Schrodinger's cat being
alive when we open the box given that
this is the state of describing the
quantum particle here's three options
for you to choose from just to test your
own knowledge and there should be a
little option up in the top right corner
to have a vote last week I spoke about
the dot product or finding the inner
product between two vectors as a way to
find how much overlap is between them
now I didn't I guess say in exact terms
how to actually find this inner product
but I want to do an example of that
using this color space example that I
use to sort of set things up in the last
episode now you know say we have these
three colors here we have pink purple
and orange they're made up of different
amounts of weird green and blue and in
this case it's like a decimal number
where the maximum value would have been
one now to find the inner product
between pink and purple we kind of
expect it to be a reasonably high number
and and saying that I mean it's
reasonably close to one these vectors
have been normalized and so that means
the length of them the length of the
victor is one so if the overlap between
them is one in there pretty much
perfectly overlapping all right so to
find the inner product what we're going
to do is take the first element of the
pink and the purple that's the
weird they have in them and times those
values together so it's going to be 0.7
for the pink times 0.5 for the purple
alright then we're going to add that
value from the multiplication to the
second element of both vectors
multiplied together so that's how much
green they have they both have zero
green zero times zero zero adding on
zero didn't change much now let's add on
the product of the third element so
that's how much blue they have in them
it's point seven for the pink in point
eight for the purple adding those three
products together for the three elements
that make up each color gives us a total
value of 0.975
now that's really close to one as you
would expect because these pink and
purple arrow are very similar colors
there we would expect a lot of overlap
here so an exercise that I went through
last time was this one here we found the
inner product or the overlap between the
spin state up and this unknown state
victor sigh which is defined as some
amount of spin up some a amount and plus
some amount B of spin down and doing
that gave us the answer
a I didn't ask you guys to do this but
it would have been very similar to
repeat doing the same thing with the
overlap between spin down and that same
state sigh if you went through that one
you would find that the answer is B and
I asked you guys to do the inner product
between the two sized states and you
would find that the answer for that was
a squared plus B squared now what are we
going to do with all that let's try and
let's try and do something with with
what we found here so what we're going
to say is that this unknown state and
remember we're calling it a kit when
it's in these kind of brackets we want
this state kit to be normalized
that means you would expect as before
that if you had the overlap between
something and itself the answer would be
one one would represent complete overlap
so we already sort of guess proved
before that the inner product of this
state and itself is a squared plus B
squared but we're also going to set that
equal to one saying that it is
normalized so we've kind of given
ourselves an identity to work with
because we also have a definition we
guess for a and for B that's what we
also work down before and if we put in
our a and I'll be into that equation to
this is the I guess final identity that
we end up with it's mostly just symbols
here but it becomes quite useful if you
look at it each squared in a product
term so that's the thing inside the
brackets corresponds to a possible
observed state that was like up or down
in terms of spin and the sum of them if
you add them together it has to equal
one and we're asked by brilliant here
what mathematical quantity has
properties like this this is how
probabilities behave if something has a
probability of one that's like a hundred
percent of something occurring if you
have two possible options or events that
could happen and they're equally likely
they would each each have a probability
of 0.5 or 1/2 meaning that if you added
those two together you'd end up with 1
means something is certainly going to
happen but there is a 50% chance of it
going one way or the other that's very
similar to what we're dealing with here
in the quantum states so this gets
pretty cool actually if you look at this
equation here this is what we've worked
up to and what it means is that each of
these squared inner product terms gives
the probability of observing each of
those states so I believe the
probability of observing a spin up state
is given by this value here and this is
the probability of observing the spin
down state now because you know like
this is equal to a as we proved before
and this is equal to B that means that a
and B are probability amplitudes that
the a and B give us the probability
of being your spin up or spin down and
that's all wrapped up in this equation
here so we want to use this new thought
and put it to the test to see if it can
help us explain some experimental
results so we're going to you finish
this quiz and move on to the next one so
we're looking again at the stern-gerlach
experiment you guys corrected me that
that's Gerlach rhymes with BAC which is
probably not what i said last time and
that was this experiment that could
measure
I guess determine if a continent state
is spin-up or spin-down
it's using some neutrons coming in here
that are in an unknown state and the
first analyzer here is you know
separating them and to spin-up and
spin-down I believe and then they're
passing into a second analyzer so
essentially we're being asked to use
those expressions we've derived for the
probability of each observation to
figure out the likelihood of the
probability of each of these question
mark States so if the unknown States
already had being measured spin up in
the first instance what's the
probability it's going to be measured
spin up again or spin down now you might
be able to work this out just by
thinking about it but let's do it with
the expressions we worked out so we
worked out the way we would figure this
out would be the probability of being
measured spin up in this second instance
would be the inner product or the
overlap of spin up and spin up if they
are normalized we'd expect complete
overlap there and so the probability
would be 1 1 squared which is 1 so
pretty much it's a hundred percent that
if something's already been measured to
be spin up then if you measure it again
it will also be spent up that is sort of
one of the inherent things about quantum
mechanics is that when you measure it it
sort of collapses into the state where
continued measurements would give you
the same result
so if we wanted to work out the second
one it would be the overlap between
being spin up and the first and
and spin-down in the second instance
because there is no overlap between
those two victors we've seen that before
there they're at 90 degrees to each
other and there are two elements of our
basis so almost by definition they have
no overlap and so the probability there
is zero squared zero this is impossible
in this next experiment we're going to
look at it's another stern-gerlach
experiment the first analyser is as
before it separates the states and to
being spin-up or spin-down and then it
goes into a second one which is aligned
a lot of different X's so it's rotated
90 degrees from the first analyzer its
magnetic field is aligned along the x
axis whereas before it was aligned along
the z axis so when these neutrons are
fired through they're being deflected
along a different axis the magnet is in
a different place so what we see is that
when we feed in something that's already
measured to be in the spin up state it's
split and equally into this spin lift
and spin right 50 is the probability of
each of these so it's equally likely to
be in either of these two streams so
what we're doing is we're thinking about
how we can represent this mathematically
I guess how we write the probability of
this happening now the way that we write
out these spin lifts and spin the write
States is as some linear combination of
spin up and spin down a and the B are
how much up and how much down to create
the spin right and then C and D
similarly early coefficients how much
spin up and spin down is involved in
that it's been left State we know that
the spin right and spin left can be
written as a linear combination of some
amounts spin up in some announcement
down because what we worked through last
time was wanting to have I guess a
well-behaved victor space so we wanted
to set up a basis
that could spare and that could create
any possibility so the basis that we
chose was that spin up and that spin
down state we chose them because we
could make any possible state as a
combination of using them so we can make
one that points to the left and one that
points to the right using these basis
vectors because that's what the basis
vectors do they can I guess make any
direction so this is how we do write it
mathematically that the probability of
being either here or here
well it's 50 percentage so we write the
overlap between the state and the state
is 1/2 and similarly the overlap between
the state and the state is also 1/2 it's
actually a system of four equations
because we also have the similar
experiment of being measured spin down
and then being measured either it's been
left or a spin right we're being asked
to determine the magnitude of a which is
I guess how much spin up there is the
probability amplitude of up in this spin
right state all right so have a little
think about it we do have three options
here on the brilliant quiz that a is 1/2
square root of 1/2 or 1 just have a
little like think about it yourself
I do have been to remember the answer to
this one from my coursework days then
the magnitude of a is the square root of
1/2 okay so apparently 81% of people got
that one right ok so let's have a look
at the solution this is what we were
starting with the definition of what it
means to be I guess spin right and we
knew this from that graphical experiment
above that this inner product is equal
to 1/2 now if we just kind of combine
those two things the late it keeps
coming up which is kind of annoying if
we write out you know the definition of
spin right inside of that probability
amplitude definition you can take the a
and the B out of the equations and we
end up with a few more inner products
where remember
they're both putting up full overlap
goes to one there pointing in opposite
direction goes to zero so you end up
with that or cancelling down to a which
means that 1/2 is equal to a is squared
because don't forget those whole set of
brackets were being squared so yeah if a
squared is equal to 1/2 then a itself
must be equal to the square root of 1/2
we can replace the a the unknown with 1
over the square root of 2 now 1 over the
square root of 2 is exactly the same as
saying the square root of 1/2 you're
just moving the square root down onto
the bottom because there's no point in
square taking the square root of the top
because that's 1 and square root of 1 is
just 1 so don't let that slight change
in notation tricky yeah so really we've
written out this spin left and spin
right with sort of one less unknown for
the spin lift state had two similar
unknown C and D which are like a and B
but I guess if you sort of think through
it the C and the a are kind of the same
so that is also the square root of 1/2
so that's been replaced as well okay so
this course thing goes in a little bit
more detail but more rigor through
finding the value of the other two
unknowns B and D I don't think I'm gonna
go through that whole derivation but the
result seems kind of obvious to me they
find that the magnitude of B and D is
also the square root of 1/2 B and D do
turn out to be going in different
directions so they have a different sign
and I think that sort of just comes out
of some of this mathematics pretty much
you find out that the spin left and spin
rights are made up of equal amount of
spin up and spin down which again it
kind of seems obvious and I think a
similar thing works out if we skip
through like spin up and spin down could
be also represented in the same way as
being equal amounts or equal
probabilities of spin left and spin
right and that's written in these two
equations there is one apparently
important curvy
listed here and they say you might be
tempted to consider the spin-up state as
describing a set containing 50% of the
neutrons in the spin left state and 50%
in the spin right state but this is not
the case the state describes a set of
identical neutrons each of which is in a
state that combines the left and right
states so they're not saying that 50% of
the neutrons that go through our in one
state or the other they're saying I
guess that every Neutron is in both of
the states they're in a superposition of
both of the states and that's a bit of a
quantum mechanics word which means I
guess yeah you are a combination of more
than one thing at the same time so let's
put this all together a little bit and
do one of the questions they say
consider a beam of neutrons which has
been prepared in an unknown alized input
state which can be described as yeah
this here three spin off plus force bend
down so normalize the state vector and
predict the probability of observing it
in either the spin up or spin down
States all right so let's work through
this on paper I think so for a
normalized state if this is our a and
this is our B then we would have that a
squared plus B squared is equal to 1
this is not what we currently have
because we have 3 squared plus 4 squared
is equal to 25 so what we want to do is
divide each of a and B by a
normalization constant such as when we
do this we want this to equal 1 so if we
have 3 over 5 squared plus 4 over 5
squared that would be equal to 1 so our
normalization constant in this case is 1
over 5 so we could then write out our
normalized state like this
our probability of being in the spin-up
state is equal to the inner product
between spin up and our normalized state
squared so that's going to work out to
be a squared which is equal to 9 over 25
that's a probability of being measured
in the spin up state very similar for
our spend-down probability it would be
the inner product between spin down and
our normalized state squared works out
to be just the value of B squared which
is this which is 16 over 25 and there's
our probability of being spin down so
here's the solution to what you saw at
the very start of the video it's an
example of the Schrodinger's cat thought
experiment in this version a cat is
stuck in a closed box with a poison vial
and a stern-gerlach analyzer with an
input state of Chi the Greek letter the
one that looks like an X here so this
Chi input state is described by you know
a superposition of spin up and spin down
the amplitude in front of both the spin
up and spin down kit is this square root
of 1/2 now that's just being taken
outside of the brackets but it is the
amplitude in front of both of those ket
states so the release valve from the
poison vial is linked to the
stern-gerlach analyzer and the valve
will be opened if a spin up Neutron is
mission before you open the box the
neutron is in a superposition of spin up
and spin down and the cat is in a
superposition of alive and dead we're
asked based on this input state try what
is the probability that Schrodinger's
cat is alive when we open the box so
based on what we know the probability of
one
of these states I guess occurring is
you're going to take the amplitude in
front of it
and you're going to square that value so
if we're going to square the one in
front of what we've got here we're going
to end up with a probability of 1/2 so
that's the correct solution here we are
like this is exactly how you would do it
mathematically here they're calculating
the inner product between spin down and
try which is I guess the probability
that the poison vial is never opened so
you can just do 1 minus whatever you're
getting out of this answer to find out
the probability that the poison is
opened so they do that in a product and
they write out try explicitly as what
we've been given to be its definition
you can take everything out you end up
with a couple of inner products that are
very familiar to us now this one is 0
and this one is 1 try and follow through
with that method right there you'll get
a half it makes sense I guess
intuitively and now it makes sense
mathematically by the end of filming
this video I feel like I've been in my
room talking to myself about quantum
mechanics for so long that I worry it
makes sense to no one except me I guess
that's my biggest fear putting this up
is that it just makes no sense at all
but it made sense to me in my brain but
yeah try and let me know like if you
could follow along with it and what I
could do to change if you want to follow
along with the exact course that I'm
using and try out some of the
interactive quiz questions for yourself
then it's all on brilliant org brilliant
are a supporter of my channel and you
can go to brilliant org slash TVs to
sign up for free you can also get 20%
off an annual premium subscription if
you're one of the first 200 people to
follow that link thanks to brilliant for
supporting my channel and I do hope you
find their content to be useful it's
definitely helping me to relearn some of
these concepts again thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next episode I
think there are maybe one or two more
episodes of this math for quantum
mechanics before we fully covered this
mathematical and
pinning in maybe we can move on to
another topic after that totally open to
suggestions of what that next topic
would be